this year we saw no shortage of
experimental indie projects and
blockbusters that defied convention to
shock audiences want to watch a film
that has you wide-eyed in open mouth by
the time the credits start to roll check
out a few of the most baffling movies of
2018 Suspiria may be a remake but this
modern take on Dario Argento's 1977 film
stands apart from other 2018 horror
films
when Suzy played by Dakota Johnson is
admitted to a dance academy in West
Berlin the Academy is still reeling over
the disappearance of a student before
her disappearance the student confessed
that she believed the Academy was run by
a coven of witches and as it turns out
she might not have been crazy after all
[Applause]
Suspiria is a disturbing body horror
packed with trippy imagery it's like
watching a feature shot in a Hall of
Mirrors
told in six distinct narrative acts the
film makes it difficult to distinguish
what's real and what's merely a product
of the characters imaginations starring
lucky Stanfield is Cassius green and
Tessa Thompson as his artistic
girlfriend Detroit sorry to bother you
begins as a film about a desperate
telemarketer trying to pay his rent but
turns into an absurdist dark comedy that
subverts all expectations by the third
act as his co-workers unionised to
protest their low pay Cassius tells
himself that he can support them from
the other side of the picket line but he
gets swept up into a conspiracy that he
never saw coming
sorry to bother you is easily one of the
strangest and best movies in decades
starring Nicolas Cage as red and Andrea
Riseborough is his titular companion
Mandy is easily some of Kage's best work
in recent years the plot follows red and
Mandy as they live a happy reclusive
life until Mandy is kidnapped by a
violent hippie cult directed by Panos
cosmatos Mandy delves into gory
psychedelic imagery that you can't look
away from as the film progresses the
line between fantasy and reality is so
heavily blurred that you're left on sure
of what to believe
assassination nation quickly builds into
something much more sinister and
terrifying than you could have ever
expected when a hacker starts revealing
the personal messages of a small town
the airing of dirty laundry turns from
petty highschool drama into a full-blown
conflict assassination nation takes a
predictable premise and jacks it all the
way up to the most extreme possible
conclusion as more secrets are revealed
the degradation of social norms occurs
so quickly that it's safe to assume it
wouldn't be a realistic turn of events
in real life but it's worth asking what
if an first reformed Reverend Ernst
Stoller holds services at a church with
a dwindling congregation as he's
grappling with the death of his son
Toller gets a frantic call from one of
his flock she's worried about her
husband Michael a radical
environmentalist who sees no hope for
the planet as Toller attempts to counsel
Mary and Michael he's forced to think
about his own beliefs and worry about
the current state of the human race
directed by Paul Schrader and starring
Ethan Hawke as Reverend Toller and
Amanda Seyfried as Mary first reformed
refuses to wrap up neatly for the viewer
after watching first reform you can't
help but wonder if the doomsday
believers have a point after all every
tiny insect the whole world is a
manifestation of his holy presence I
think this is an issue where the church
can lead annihilation is one of those
genre-bending films that combines the
best of science fiction and horror into
a single compelling storyline Cain
played by Oscar Isaac is the only
survivor of an expedition into the
shimmer an electromagnetic field that's
spreading on the southern coast of the
United States what really happened while
he was inside and was it really Kane who
came back a scientist played by Natalie
Portman is determined to find out with
her own expedition as she ventures into
the shimmer herself nothing is quite
what it seems in me
who will be in all of us the happy time
murders follows a human and puppet
detective team as they try to figure out
who's behind the recent murders of
retired sitcom stars with puppets
engaging in everything from violent
crime to petty theft and raunchy jokes
it's like a twisted look at your
childhood favorites you won't be able to
look at a puppet quite the same way
after watching the happy time murders
sure you've got to give the cast and
crew props for their willingness to get
creative in the medium but it's hard not
to wonder why this story had to be told
with puppets which is truly baffling in
Madeline's Madeleine Helena Howard stars
as Madeleine a young woman who joins a
prestigious physical theatre troupe her
intensely ambitious director pushes her
to explore her family trauma through her
art particularly her relationship with
her mother but Madeline's performance
begins to cross from art into life until
the two become completely
indistinguishable at its core Madeline's
Madeleine is a film about acting it
represents a look inside the mind of an
artist
complete with dizzying dramatic
cinematography the characters explore
identity through performance and the
movie encourages viewers to consider how
much of our own identities are authentic
parts of who we are and how much is
merely a performance for others excuse
me
yeah okay great in the suspenseful
thriller unsane Claire Foy plays Sawyer
a woman who moves away from home to
escape her stalker but even after she
thinks she's in the clear
Sawyer struggles to move on and meets
with a counselor to dig into the healing
process unfortunately she ends up being
tricked into a long-term stay in a
psychiatric institution where she makes
a terrifying discovery watching unsane
will have you questioning everyone
around you four days after your name is
Sawyer Valentini you know that already
by signing this you've consented to
voluntary commitment for 24 hours No